do you believe that the problem of
senescence to the degree can be called a
problem is largely a disruption of
this electrical blueprint rather than
oxidative stress and damage to dna and
so on that or telomeric length that
people think
um i don't have any evidence yet that
there's a bioelectric component to this
i mean i suspect there is but but we
don't have any evidence on it we haven't
really worked on aging per se
i will say that i don't think it's
anything as fundamental as uh this kind
of like thermodynamic decay or anything
like that because the planaria are
immortal they don't have a a life span
limit they live forever and so they are
telling us that it's possible to be a
complex regenerative organism with uh
learning capacity and so on and not age
so so so it's clearly possible so so the
rest is details right the rest is uh i
don't think it's anything as fundamental
as
the the the theories that say well look
when you copy things you inevitably make
mistakes so eventually stuff whereas it
wears out if that were true
you wouldn't have plenary so so i don't
think i don't think it's anything like
that i think it's something much more
contingent much more specific uh and and
thus i i'm optimistic that we can
overcome it